I wanna be a billionaire so so bad by
all of the things I never had I wanna be
on the cover of forbes magazine there
you go there's a line everything we got
hired to do a gig to produce for UK act
this was at a time when we had no money
and I just started humming I want to be
a billionaire so fricking bad you know
then I wouldn't have this problem I want
to be worried about I can't eat an
omelet in the morning and that's what I
came from and I asked my friend are I
said yo is this cool I want to be in a
color forbes magazine smiling next to
Oprah and the Queen he said oh yeah it's
great we should go with it so we came
back to LA and finished it plated for
travis mccoy and he made it the song it
was made it this kind of like universal
wish record whenever you get the chance
to do what you love and you get paid to
do it it's just it's newborn it's the
greatest thing ever but it's also just
very just weird you know it's it's it's
it doesn't feel like I should be
compensated for doing something that I
love doing so much and then it's so so
they're beautiful what do you think the
biggest advantages and disadvantages are
of youth the biggest advantage is um
being able to go anywhere and do
anything talk to people people really
you know genuinely loving you and being
inspired by what you do um the
disadvantages are just people feeling
like they know you just based off of
what they might see and it feel like
they kind of separate the fact that
you're a normal person away from your
celebrity the social media was helped
launch my career without the internet
and without YouTube you know I wouldn't
have gotten a chance to put my music out
there and have people here
for the first time and I was like me
there's a friend of mine show me this
program called FL studio which I still
used today like I just got home like
instantly and I've been you know I've
been playing some guitar before and
plays on piano but not that well but
when I downloaded this like I could
really tell that I proved quickly
no job back and my mum and dad started
messing around with music just for fun
rather than music to try and get a
record deal which is what i was doing
before same sort of time myspace was
getting big um set up a myspace account
started adding people but i thought were
loosely connected to the industry like
songwriters odd anrs so i happen to add
and one week the guy who ended up
signing into emi publishing and my no
manager I was like a jerk of my beads to
say I wouldn't I did what everyone
within that month I'd signed the deal
and I'm starting my last check and rest
on the shelf I flow so sick you might
want to absorb this best believe every
year you're capable make that Forbes in
this